le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
au côté des
Réunionnais l'île de la Réunion possède
toutes les qualités pour être
autosuffisante en énergie la chaleur du
volcan le vent les vagues le soleil tous
ces atouts font de notre île un exemple
en la matière mais pour envisager un
futur écologique au plus haut point il
faut aussi que la population réunonnaise
joue le je et adopte une attitude
éccitoyenne alors qui peut nous
enseigner les gestes à adopter qui peut
apporter les moyens et les outils
nécessaires à un tel apprentissage on en
parle maintenant dans lien
[Musique]
social il y a encore quelques années
nous n'avions pas conscience de nos
actes sur
l'écosystème aujourd'hui grâce à une
communication importante sur ce sujet
nous avons bien plus conscience de nos
actes mais il il existe peu d'endroits
où on nous apprend à agir comme il le
faudrait des endroits où on nous
enseigne l'attitude
écitoyenne c'est en faisant ce constat
qu'un établissement des haut de
Sainte-Marie a eu l'idée d'intégrer de
manière plus concrète un programme
permettant de sensibiliser efficacement
les élèves de leur collège donc le
projet a démarré il y a 5 ans et en fait
suite à une demande du principal adjoint
madame Dufour à l'époque qui euh nous a
proposé un concours entre les des élèves
de du collège de La Réunion du collège
bosséjour et l'Afrique du Sud sur le
développement durable ce qu'on pouvait
apporter chacun à son son île ou son
pays et donc on a recruté un certain
nombre d'élèves volontaires et quand on
a vu la motivation qu'ils avaient eu à
faire ce travail on a décidé de
continuer sur quelque chose concernant
le développement durable donc on a
demandé aux élèves de chercher un petit
peu sur internet ce qui pouvait exister
comme type de projet et on est tombé sur
l'éco-école au fur et à mesure dans
l'année ces élèves ont participé et au
jardinage et à la prise de contact avec
une association qui était les amis des
plantes et de la nature la PPN qui nous
ont fourni des plantes endémiques que
finalement les élèves qui faisaient
jardinage entre midi et de ont fini par
planter à la fin de l'année donc
maintenant on a dans ce collège depuis 4
ans quelques espèces quelques
exemplaires d'espèces endémiques qui qui
pousseent avec des petits panneaux
inscrits et fixés sur des gros rochers
donc que tous les élèves peuvent
lire tout le monde c'est vraiment
retrouvver le Conseil général est venu
la mairie est venue le parc national est
venu on a tous retrouvé ensemble sur ce
ce projet qui a fédéré comme ça un grand
groupe de personnes grâce aussi au fait
que les élèves étaient très volontaires
puisque quand on on appelle une
entreprise on appelle une collectivité
locale en disant on est 100 150 élèves à
travailler sur ce projet on a tout de
suite du poids et ça a réunit tout le
monde ce côtél qui était très sympa dans
dans le
projet devant un tel succès et une telle
implication des élèves les professeurs
et l'ensemble du personnel du collège
les ont soutenu et encouragé à
s'impliquer davantage ils ont proposé
des solutions pour gérer l'eau les
déchets et l'électricité là encore la
prise de conscience a été immédiate et
surtout
efficace grâce à cela les élèves ont
fait preuve de solidarité et apprennent
le savoir vivre ensemble l'année
dernière donc un travail autour du thème
de déchets et particulièrement des
déchets alimentaires parce que ce que je
regrette c'est que quand on voit les
problématiques de de la fin dans le
monde quand on voit même près de chez
nous des jeunes qui ont du mal à ne
serait-ce à manger régulièrement et je
parle même de même pas équilibré c'est
manger tout simplement on a fait des
pesés aussi de de de poubelle avec les
restes alimentaires pour là aussi
essayer de tendre vers moins de de de de
déchets alimentaires et pour
sensibiliser les élèves sur cette
priorité à mon sens de de respect de la
nourriture et de respect là aussi du du
travail des uns et des autres bien sûr
des cuisiniers qui font les les repas
les les agents qui servent enfin et
cetera et cetera voyant un talengouement
pour ce projet le Conseil général a
décidé d'apporter son aide il a donc
subventionné les travaux comme
l'installation et la pose de panneaux
solaires avec un tableau de consommation
d'énergie permettant aux élèves d'avoir
une vision sur la production d'énergie
au collège on doit apprendre également à
nos jeunes à aimer la nature la nature
qui est très belle à la Réunion en ayant
à l'esprit qu'il faut préserver notre
environnement qu'il faut aussi faire en
sorte que nos forêts nos espaces
naturels sensibles descendent de la haut
vers les bas c'est pour ça que nous
participons à cette opération éch école
28 collèges où il y a des cons cours
ouvert où on embellit où le cadre de vie
des collégiens et ben accompagne
également l'idée que ça peut être beau
ça peut être un endroit agréable venir à
l'école et ben il faut que on se dise
qu'il y a un petit plus on se sent un
peu comme dans son jardin donc c'est
vrai que c'est une belle opération nous
accompagnons donc les équipes
pédagogiques et je crois qu'il faut
remercier l'ensemble des professeurs qui
se sont investi sur cette belle
opération tout simplement parce que
c'est saint exupéri qui l'a dit nous
n'héritons pas de la terre que nous
avons nous nous l'empruntons au fond à
nos enfants faisons en sorte que cette
belle terre reste pour les générations à
venir une terre agréable tout simple à
vivre la réunion a été déclarée
Patrimoine mondial de l'humanité par
l'UNESCO pour 44 % de sa
superficie ce titre est une preuve
incontestable que notre île mérite
d'être
préservée cette préservation sera
durable en apprenant à nos enfants
comment entretenir écologiquement notre
département le Conseil Général de la
Réunion vous a présenté lien social le
Conseil général au côté des
Réunionnais